very few times you see people cooking
hash way when it's only one or two
people in the house it's always when
there is gathering when there is
festivity going on around the house
my name is rabia Bashara I come from
Nazareth Palestine I own a restaurant in
barrage Brooklyn called tenure in
caterers if I sat down and Thanksgiving
table and there was no harsh way I will
eat whatever is on the table but I'm
sure I won't be as satisfied
I think cash way is a good thing to have
next to Turkey the world has you need
stuffing that's why we call it hash way
because we stop things with it in Egypt
they call it Rose's ball Sultan they
have it in Jordan they have it in Syria
they have it in Lebanon they have it in
most of the Arab countries we come from
very warm very loving families loving
mothers and fathers it spend time
cooking and shopping and preparing and
on meals together on tables around
dinner tables the perfect hash with my
mom's hash it should fill up your senses
when you put it in your mouth you feel
like you have a whole meal she was the
greatest ago we always knew it was in
the back of her mind that she wished she
can open her restaurant but in those old
days nobody did that in Nazareth so I
often turn her in to really honored